i do believe that humans have a  tremendous capacity to endure and  persist but that few human beings  actually know how to tap into that  system except under conditions of  extreme survival and you also hear from  really good physicians ones that aren't  into woo biology or woo psychology at  all that to some extent yes there are  people that unfortunately die in their  battle against cancer no matter what but  the desire to continue living is a  powerful force in of itself setting of  milestones and the ability to generate  dopamine and  adrenaline is what allows people to  persist and live longer there's no  question about that